this is from The Daily Mail quote it
wasn't me footage shows millionaire Tech
entrepreneurs final words after being
fatally shot by a trigger-happy cop
while defending his home from a
suspected burglar I'm going to give you
the basis of basics of this story Rajan
mooning's Moon and Singh I'm pronouncing
his name wrong he's dead
He's 33 years old he was a tech
entrepreneur he lived in South Austin
and apparently the story is he heard a
noise and he thought someone broke into
his house so he took his I believe he
had an AR he carried it around and it
looked like he had it low ready
he checked the perimeter of his house
when the cops pull up the cops within
seconds yell dropped the gun and before
he even finishes saying the word bang
bang bang bang
killing this guy they didn't he didn't
die instantly he fell to the ground and
yelled it wasn't me it wasn't me they
brought into the hospital he died this
guy was just legally protecting his own
house and these cops went nuts and Texas
is an open carry state so if we had
every legal right to do that I think his
family should actually sue the Austin
Police Department absolutely but but you
know even even outside of open carry
he's on his own property he's in his own
house and these cops just assume without
even stopping on and questioning the
reason I want to talk about this story
if one obviously with you Kyle here but
also because in the past couple of weeks
we had we had several incidents I I
can't talk about Muslim but I can talk
about the one where a shot was fired at
some Intruders who broke into my house
this they we've been swatted 15 times
we've had the bomb squad show up twice
this is what they are doing so when I
say they are trying to kill us it's
because they want this to happen they're
hoping that the first time they do it
knowing that we live in a castle
doctrine State and we are armed they're
hoping that we go outside to inspect the
screaming and the crazy noise and the
cops get trigger happy fortunately we
have measures in place and that stupid
idea isn't going to work you take a look
at what happens and this is what's
currently happening in in this in modern
politics
absolutely like I agree with you 100
they are trying to get us killed they're
trying to take out Conservancy they're
trying to like this is an attack on the
Second Amendment or a way too
because people I believe everybody
should have a gun but then people are
going to be afraid to go and purchase a
gun if they know if they go and check
their property that they're going to be
shot and killed for simply doing what
they're doing yeah these officers need
to be fired immediately they need at
least they only need to be charged they
need to be charged yeah absolutely
charge them I absolutely agree with you
I mean they they took an innocent life
that wasn't doing anything wrong wasn't
breaking any laws was protecting his own
home and property they were clearly not
trained right exactly yeah he didn't
point the gun at them he he didn't fire
off around an officer who clearly didn't
know what he was doing made some people
would say he made a mistake some people
let's let's say you pulled the article
because they don't there's nothing
graphic in this video that I have right
here you can just see the dude Raj look
how he's carrying his weapon he's not
even pointing it he's holding it down at
his side he does lift it up but this is
before the full cops arrived this was
him checking his perimeter
when the incident question happened he
was not pointing anything at anybody
he's on his own property and they and
they shoot him but I want to say
something too because you said they're
trying to take out conservatives it's
more than that I mean I don't look the
the right they they call me liberal the
left they call me conservative Luke's
certainly not a conservative Ian
certainly not a conservative I'm
obviously some weird Centrist that has
you know a little bit of liberal a
little bit of conservative but this is
not a far-right show that's not a
conservative show but is a show that
tries to be honest it's a show that
calls out psychological operations from
centcom happening on Twitter we will
will call out the lies we'll present the
evidence and just try and give people a
real view that is a threat to the
narrative in the machine but I'll tell
you this the fact that they've been
swatting us and it's not working another
white pill moment they can't stop us
a question about this guy that was
killed did he call the police himself
and say that he thought there was an
intruder on his property so my
understanding of the story is that it
was a neighbor
a neighbor saw him patrolling his
property and said it looks like there
may be a break-in or something's
happening
so the cops pull up
they see a guy in what looks like
pajamas with a rifle and he says drop
the gun bang bang bang you might have
had like a coyote on his property or
something like no one knows why he was
out there apparently he said something
like he thought he was there was someone
in his house he he so the guard said in
a call to dispatcher he almost seems to
be scared of something inside his house
so what what about the neighbor the
neighbor that instigated this should
that person be charged too did you guys
see the video there's an old I think it
was an old black man watering flowers
and the cops shop and they're like what
are you doing and he's like watering the
flowers and they're like do you live
here and he's like no this is my
friend's house and they were like the
why are you here he's like my friend's
out of town they asked me to water their
flowers I live next door and they're
like you're under arrest they arrest the
guy yeah my response none of your
business I believe the fifth yo and and
they were like give us your ID and the
neighbors are like oh yeah yeah we
didn't realize that was him he is
friends with this guy and the cops are
like don't care then there's a video out
of Florida where a guy who's legally
blind is walking down the street with
his walking cane in his pocket he's he's
not Pitch Black blind he's blind to
where everything's blurry but he can
walk without you know hitting something
and so this lady cop she she's like
what's in your pocket and he's like
holds it up so walking cane are we done
and she goes give me your ID and he goes
what no I don't have to they arrest him
I'm sick of this man I mean Kyle when
you were turning yourself in the police
officers pepper sprayed you yeah I went
up to the police car
um my pepper sprayed Kyle when he was uh
surrender to the police that night when
you walked by so after my after after
the incident happened that night I
walked up to the police car hands in the
air I told the officer I was like I just
shot somebody I just shot somebody I was
pepper sprayed I don't remember being
pepper spray but it's not in videos
so I'm not disputing that to happen he
just sprays you I read the police report
the police report said they pepper
sprayed me and pointed a gun at me wow
they're not there for you and they don't
care they're not there for anybody for
the city just to think
they they could have they could have the
police could have killed me that night
with my hands in the air if I didn't
step away from the police car I think in
any in any sane Society well me and Tim
got guns uh pulled on us by Chicago
police officers that's Chicago Police I
took out a camera and they thought you
know the camera could have been
something they literally freaking cocked
a gun well well so we get surrounded by
like 12 vehicles in Chicago they start
walking to the car it's an illegal
search in my opinion banging on it
saying out of the car guns drawn they
pull us out they Frisk us they took our
credit card numbers they wrote them down
they wrote down passport numbers from
our IDs and they started trying to find
secret compartments in the car they were
banging on our equipment thinking it was
like fake and then also some cop they
cuffed me and then this guy cuffed me
too yeah this cop box up and he goes you
match the description and then he makes
a gesture and then the uncuffing they'll
like get out meanwhile the car we had
had New Mexico plates and we were in
Chicago and I'm like match the
description of what it was there a crime
with the with the car with the Chicago
plate with it with uh with a New Mexico
plate in Chicago ago that made
absolutely no sense at all 12 squad cars
uh it was again another incident that we
had to deal with one of many that I had
to deal with that is just absolutely
Draconian and insane and we need
pushback against these officers that are
just following orders doing what they're
told I don't understand people who could
back the blue I don't understand
individuals who could still do this
after everything that's been happening
to be honest with you you know I don't
think it's police on their own I think
police are inherently good I think the
law enforcement I think they go in there
to do good things I'm I'm pro-blue
that's okay but I think I'm pro-blue I
think it's in the leadership I think the
leadership there are like appointed
Chiefs who are appointed by these
liberals and these officers are scared
to do the right thing I mean look at the
officer who was fired for donating to my
legal defense he was fired I don't think
it's necessarily the officers but I
think it's the sergeants who are maybe
like sucking up to the supervisors and
people in the department trying to get a
promotion not the officers who are out
there doing the right thing on a daily
basis you're right about the super
supervisors but in terms of the place in
general people are people right there's
a they're good cops the ones that were
defending you and then there are bad
cops who just don't care and will just
follow orders but just like in any
career there's right there's bad
journalists but there's also good
journalists not all cops are bad but
there's also very huge there's also very
few good journalists and let's be honest
here there's also very few good cops
here a lot of them are order followers a
lot of them predominantly generate
revenue for the state and in many
instances in my life and in many
instances of of the average American's
life when they need them they're not
there for them there there are a few
instances where they are and they
deserve to be commended and respected
but very rarely I mean there's laws on
the books here in the United States that
says the police officers do not have a a
duty to protect you and there's been
multiple cases especially with my friend
Joe lazito in New York City where there
was a lunatic a mass murderer running
around that was stabbing my friend Joe
in the head police officers were
standing there watching by then of
course when Joe took them down police
officers took credit for taking them
down even though they never did and then
they claimed Joe was a victim when Joe
was the actual hero of that day Joe
lazito's Survival Story look it up be
prepared to be shocked to see what
police officers could do so I'm looking
at what's going on a lot now with these
cops and a lot of them are following
orders kovid I think proved too many too
many of these cops will destroy you for
their own personal gain yeah we saw
state troopers go into a bar in New York
because they the bar wanted to open and
New York was like nope you got to shut
down a block away it was a green zone
where businesses were allowed to operate
so the bar owner is basically like okay
we're not selling anything more it's a
hangout everything's free so this so the
the the the local cops were like I'm not
I'm not going anywhere near this they'll
destroy my life my neighbor's looking
mad at me so they called in state
troopers to come and block the doors and
those cops were like don't know don't
care you can't live your life Kyle but I
want to make sure I say this too because
it's it's not fair to to only highlight
the bad I do want to tell a story of
when I was in Chicago and some guy tried
mugging me and out of nowhere three cops
popped out and grabbed this guy and
slammed him into a iron fence and this
this is like a 55 year old fat white cop
with gray hair grabbed the guy by the
collar spun him around slammed him into
a fence and screamed not in my town in
his face and they asked me if I was okay
he asked me to file a report and they
they legitimately popped that was a rare
experience for me but I don't want to
sit here and just be like all cops are
bad all cops are bad I've had good
experiences but I've had too many bad
experiences they need to not be
empowered to make those bad decisions
and when they make bad decisions and
when they make bad calls they should be
held responsible for it and let's be
honest rarely do they ever get held
responsible for it you look at what
happened in Uvaldi you look at what
happened in Parkland police officers
there literally stood down well those
those guys are getting held accountable
aren't they like they're getting in
trouble getting criminally charged yes
but those are two egregious Mainline big
stories that the world has heard of
there's other stories that that didn't
make the narrative that didn't make uh
National headlines where we see this
time and time again as far as Uvaldi you
have to fight to get Justice in these
particular cases you shouldn't we should
have a system where if someone makes a
mistake or someone hurts someone else
they actually get held responsible there
shouldn't be victims family members in
Parkland coming forward and demanding
Justice for the officers that were just
standing by with their hands in their
pocket that's what I'm calling for again
judge a person by their character not by
who they are but at the end of the day I
think we have a core systemic uh
corruption issue you mean judge them by
by their character and who they are but
not their jobs exactly yeah yeah yeah I
think in some Essence like most a
promissor is a corruption issue like we
don't get good sheriffs elected there
are a lot of great sheriffs out there
but look at the county I grew up in Lake
County Illinois I think that sheriff is
as corrupt as they get I think it's a
department issue with the head I don't
think it's necessarily the officer I
think it may be the officers scared to
disobey out of fear of losing their
pension their job because they have
families they need to provide for but
that's the same that's just that's the
same argument that you know a lot of
German SS officers were making when they
were putting people into camps right
they didn't want to be in camps
themselves they said we'll go along with
it so I'll say you're right it's the
leadership and a lot of these guys don't
know and this is another big challenge I
remember I asked uh uh I remember asking
a active service member 15 years ago
if you were instructed to shoot a
civilian walking down the street by your
commanding officer would you do it and
they said yeah that sounds like a really
crazy question right like as if to imply
some military officer or some Soldier is
so stupid and so so you know brainwashed
that they would kill an innocent person
but think about what this means if if
you are in an active conflict situation
and you are ordered stop that person
this could be a person onto the weapon
we don't know about this could be a
person who's got a bomb that we don't
know about they're telling you you have
to stop them because you trust the
people you're with not to hurt innocent
people so you think about this is the
issue with police right just sorry to
make the point you got a regular cop
who's like 24 25 years old and he's told
you need to arrest this guy
he's not going to stop and say well my
my Superior officer told me I need to
arrest you but I want to hear your side
of the story no he's going to be like
this guy's dangerous and and they want
me to stop him so I agree with you on
supervisors but there's got to be some
some degree of pushback with a story
like this where the homeowners killed
that dude should not have just jumped
out and shot him that's not an issue of
superior officers no I agree with that
instance and you got to think about this
for a second police officers responded
to a lot of these scenes they're getting
they're getting told what's happening
via radio and a lot of miscommunication
like they like hear it may get lost in
the connection you're talking to 9-1-1
they're talking to the person sitting
next to them they're relating to the
officer the officers adrenaline's
pumping they're going lights and Sirens
to get to that situation they could be
hearing there's a man with the gun this
that and that and then they get there
there's a person with a gun they don't
know what's happening and then
it could also be how the officers train
I don't know how Austin PD trains their
officers but thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time